the raiders excited to meet the colts  this sunday chris matthews joins us now  with some good news on the  injury front chris yeah kirsten there  really is this is the nfl every single  team has injuries to deal with don't  know if the raiders have  any more than any other team that's been  hit hard but throwing the covid boy it  seems like the raiders have had more  than their fair share  of players missing games good news for  the raiders  as they make that playoff push they're  getting some players back looks like  trent brown jonathan abram and josh  jacobs will play against the  indianapolis colts on sunday remember  the raiders are sitting one game behind  the colts in that chase for an afc  wild card spot